thank you
and you should see it was nice
today
um everyone uh so uh baras aha will now
be speaking
um she's a professor at youth Cafe
University of San Diego and she's been
doing a lot of cool work on at a
distance among other problems and
probably telling us about how to compute
at a distance in the fully Dynamic model
thank you Julian
so it's great to be here and yeah so
I'll be talking about
edit distance
in the fully Dynamic model and this is a
joint work with my ex post Arc too much
so what is edit distance I guess all of
you know so it's a
very fundamental measure of computing
distance between sequences introduced
way back in 1965 by Levin Stein so
basically you're given two sequences you
want to know how many what are the
minimum number of edits insertion
deletion and substitutions are required
to convert one sequence into another so
for example if you have two sequences
like this here if you are deleting B
then you're substituting this B with an
A and then you are inserting B over here
uh or deleting B over here or inserting
V over here then with three edits you
can convert X to Y so that the distance
between X and Y is three if there's a
lot of applications uh comparing DNA and
RNA sequences comparing languages text
communication streams etc etc
so how do you compute any distance this
is something you learn in an
undergraduate course
so basically you can write the first
sequence here and on the top and the
second sequence on the left this is you
can do it using dynamic programming but
here is a another way of viewing the
dynamic programming to compute at a
distance it's like this is your grid
like graph and here on the horizontal
edges so each node has three edges
horizontal vertical and diagonal on the
horizontal Edge you have all the
horizontal edges have weight one what
does that mean that means like you are
deleting the deleting the deleting a
deleting B so these are deletions over
here so cost one so all horizontal edges
have cost one similarly vertical edges
means deletion over here so all the
vertical edges have caused one the only
the diagonal edges might have caused 0
over 1 based on whether the two symbols
matches or not like here B and B matches
so the cost is zero here A and B they
don't match so the cost is one okay so
you have this grid like graph and then
the edit distance is simply like
Computing the shortest path from this
point here uh to here
okay and this can be done this is like N
squared nodes N squared just so here if
you if you do this this will be your
shortest path and you can compute uh the
distance in
this shortest part on the grid graph can
be computed in N Square time so you can
compute that a distance is an in square
trying time and this is also optimal
considering the strong exponential time
hypothesis okay
so this rates show them where the edits
happen so there is a deletion here there
is a substitution here and there is a
dilation here
okay so now we are considering the
dynamic model so what does the dynamic
model means here like in the dynamic
model we are first given two strings X
and Y but now we are allowed to make
changes on the string so you can
substitute symbols in a X or Y you can
insert you can delete and those
positions could be arbitrary it could be
at the beginning it could be at the end
it could be at the middle anywhere is
possible okay and you have to maintain
the edit distance very fast with these
Dynamic changes
so it could be the applications could be
like genome sequences they go through
mutations documents they go through
revisions Etc etcetera
and we want to trade off like the
goodness of estimate uh what kind of
estimate you can give for a distance
with the update
okay so this is your Dynamic edit
distance problem
now if you look at the dynamic
programming table or the shortest path
computation here if you make even little
change like if you make a substitution
here like all these diagonal edges are
going to change so lots of entries in
your shortest in your dynamic
programming table are the shortest path
computation actually changes or even
worse like if you make some deletion
it's possible like hint if everything
changes okay so you cannot really simply
check the dynamic programming
computation or the shortest path
computation and make and try to make
them dynamic
so what is known here in the dynamic
model for computing at a distance well
previously most of the works had
considered restricted models in the
restricted models the ins the edits are
only allowed on the either end okay
either at the beginning or at the or at
the end
and there has been some work that does
that and they still require linear
update time and they are Computing
things exactly but the rest the model is
restricted
the fully Dynamic model as far as we can
tell the only considered in 2020
where they where the update time is
still linear and you can return an exact
answer
but this linear is the best that you can
hope for
because if you are considering like you
can insert one at a time like you can
within updates you can construct your
interest ring so if you if you can get
anything better than n then even in the
static setting you will get something
better than n Square which is not
possible using the strong exponential
time hypothesis therefore linear update
time is the best possible when you are
trying to compute at a distance exactly
okay
and there are other models that have
been also very well studied in at a
distance computation like streaming and
so on
the question that we are really asking
here okay so for exact computation I
need linear updates so what about
approximate computation
there has been tremendous progress on
approximating edit distance in the last
two decades so the so the question is
can we utilize that progress and get
something significantly sub-linear
update time for approximating edit tests
okay so that's what we are asking so
right now what we know we have a
constant Factor approximation that runs
in near linear Time by Anthony andazaska
from 2020 we have a three plus Epsilon
approximation that runs in sub quadratic
time then there has been a lot of
progress on some linear time
approximation of edit distance as well
so the question is can we utilize the
progress in first approximation
algorithms for edit distance to get a
good Dynamic algorithm for it okay so
this is a valid question
uh and we will see what we can do but
before we do that like let's go back so
we are we are so so this is what we are
trying to do we are trying to use these
algorithms as a black box and get a fast
Dynamic algorithm for that data so
that's kind of the first thing that we
are trying okay so even to do that we
have to uh go back a little bit like not
not a little bit we have to go back walk
or like a way in a piece to understand
um one another algorithm for edit
distance which computes I did distance
exactly it looks at the dynamic
programming table but actually the
algorithm is in is a greedy it's a
greedy algorithm okay so that uh
utilizes what is known as LC queries
which is longest common extension so
what it does it computes the farthest
furthest row with cost 0 1 2 and so on
okay so you're starting your computation
right over here and you are asking how
far can I go with cost of zero
so how far can you go you can follow
this diagonal B and B matches so you can
go up to here but if you try to extend
anywhere here you will incur a cost so
this is the farthest you can go with
cost of zero okay so after that you were
asking how far can I go with cost of one
so what can can you do here you can come
over here right pay the substitution
here but then if you want to progress
you will get stuck or you can pay a
deletion here and you can try to follow
this zero weight path right or you can
do a deletion here and you can try to
follow the zero weight path over here
so you can try to do this and this is
how far you can go with the cost of one
so now here you are then you are asking
how far can I go with the cost of two so
what can you do like you can you can
come over here but then you get stuck
you can you can come over here by doing
a deletion you again get stuck you can
come over here you get stuck uh you can
you can come over here now you can
follow this zero length path up to here
and so on okay so this this is this is
how far you can go with cost of one then
cost of two you can in fact reach over
here
and then with the cost of three you will
be reaching here okay so this is this is
a greedy algorithm that computes the
edit distance and what you see here that
if your edit if you are trying to
understand whether your edit distance is
bounded by some small k then you own
your computation only needs to consider
K diagonals on the top K diagonals at
the end
below around the main diagonal okay and
in each diagonal you are you are you are
kind of keeping track of these points
like cos 0 cost 1 cos two cos 3 and so
on so you're you're keeping track of K
points in each of the 2K plus one
diagonals okay and between these points
what do you have you have like a
matching substring here like all zero
cost these are called LC queries the
longest common extension so this is the
part where you have exact matching a b
matches with a B so these are your
longest common extension
so if I tell you I can pre-process the
string so that I can answer this longest
common extension queries in constant
time then how then what is the running
time of this algorithm well you have 2K
plus one diagonals and in every diagonal
you have K search points like you have
to ask this LC queries K Times Bar
diagonal there are 2K plus one diagonals
overall you have to ask for LC queries K
Square thing
okay so that gives you uh n plus K
Square time algorithm
um n plus K Square time algorithm for
computing that it is
and it also tells you if you if you
allow for pre-processing on the back of
on the back end then in case Square time
you can compute the edit distance
exactly which is great if K is small but
obviously K could be large and in that
case you are still
um
heading there in square thing
one advantage of this algorithm is that
this pre-processing the data structure
for LC query you can maintain it in the
dynamic way so even even when the
strings are going through our bets you
can maintain the data structure for LC
queries and after that obviously you can
run this algorithm in K Square time so
this algorithm back from 1988 actually
works in the dynamic setting with an
update time of K Square which is great
for small K but not so good if the K is
large
so what is our first fasting that we are
going to do like we are going to use
this algorithm when my case small and
when my K is large I'm I'm going to use
the recent developments in the car in
the approximating first approximation
algorithms for edit distance okay so
here we are trying to use the use this
algorithms as black box and we are
trying to see how far can we go using
them as Black Box
so what we do so so when the distance is
small we'll be running this order K
Square algorithm
but we do not need to run this order at
a square algorithm after every update
if you are allowing say constant Vector
approximation we can run it after every
K object
okay so since we know license we are
trying to say k k and 2K are fine so
it's not that we have to run this K
Square algorithm after every update we
can run it after every K of that okay so
then the amorta is time update time
becomes order k
so that's from the
the algorithm that is that I just showed
you so this achieves constant Factor
approximation amortized time order k but
now when K is large what we will do we
can run this algorithm that runs in into
the one plus Epsilon time but again we
will do that after every K update
so this Epsilon depends on the
approximation Factor so there if the
approximation is some function of
Epsilon okay one over itself
and if you if you want like not constant
Factor but some into the C approximation
you can in fact run a sublinear Time
algorithm after every K update switches
the running time
so that's fastening that we do
and now you have to balance like if you
are using Anthony nozusky and the small
distance you are doing this large
distance you are doing this then you
just balance K with this and that gives
you amortized update time moving to the
0.5 Plus
and if you want to do into this
approximation you balance K with
whatever is written here and that will
give you a amortized update time of n to
the 0.5 minus C
okay so what do you see here that using
the state of the art known algorithms
has Black Box the object time times
approximation factor is n to the 0.5
okay so now the question that we are
asking can we do better than this
so our resources as follows so what we
do is we reduce the update time times
approximation factor from n to the 0.5
to any arbitrary into the Epsilon for
any arbitrary Epsilon greater than zero
okay uh
so in fact what we get like given a
parameter B so this is going to be our
average time which is P Square log n to
the Power log b n and this approximation
factor is be lucky and but if you set
the parameters properly then you will
get a
H um after time I went to the Epsilon
for an approximation factor of poly log
you will get a sub polynomial of the
time for an approximation factor of like
sub polynomial approximation factors
or that lower bound
no does that and we have an algorithm
for it so what we have what I'm trying
to say here yes so I didn't explain this
explain this line so the algorithm that
we give so I'm saying that update time
times approximation factor of our
algorithms into the Epsilon with the
caveat that the approximation Factor the
best approximation factor that we can
achieve is poly login so we cannot go
down to constant factor and that's
remains as a one of the main open
question after all
okay so the best approximation factor
that we can achieve is poly login but
then the update time is into the Epsilon
previously using the Black Box uh for
even with all the recent developments
what you could achieve is it to the 0.5
any question so far
so the
problem definition the model are okay
right
so now we are trying to develop now now
I will try to tell you some of the high
level ideas about how you get to that
this into the Epsilon update time with
polylog approximation
so first of all if I'm trying
to design
a good Dynamic algorithm
or not only just edit distance maybe for
anything
I would need to find some small
independent problems so that from their
solution I can get a goodest good
estimate of
my final distance okay so maybe what I
can do I can take my X
I can start partitioning X into smaller
and smaller parts until it becomes like
one element at the leaf so this becomes
a tree and then I will take each of
these small parts and I will try to
compare it with some suitable support of
Y okay so that could be one way of
partitioning X so you will compare parts
of X with the weight appropriate parts
of Y and I will partition X okay so that
could be one way of breaking into
Independence problems and another
property that I should have that when an
update happens
which that should not affect
too many of these independent problems
okay so if an update happens here
it should affect only a few problems few
sub problems
if an update affects here
it should it should affect only a few
Supra
if you have these two properties then
there is a hope that that you can you
can you can come up with a good dynamic
algorithm so update does not affect too
many sub problems so we tried to see
like is there any work out there for
static algorithms for approximating
distance that has
go back a quite a bit in 20 to 2010
to see that indeed there has been a work
by andhuri and unak who introduced this
notion of tree distance that kind of has
this fear
okay that kind of has this property and
in 2010 this was a big result like they
achieved the fast near linear time
algorithm for poly log approximation
okay so and then after that there was a
long hair test till 2018
um when people came up with constant
patterns approximation but in some
quadratic time and now finally we have
constant Factor approximation in near
linear time but at that time this was a
big result
and this seems like out of all the
static algorithms much more amenable for
what is tree distance again for tree
distance so I have to Define tree
distance so what is three distance you
take X again you keep on becoming
partitioning X into smaller and smaller
parts until you have the leaf level you
have just one entry
okay so you build this tree so here this
tree is binary I'm showing it a binary
but actually this binary won't work at
all you will have a much higher addity
of the tree
okay so you decompose this x now you
take uh
but a node V so this V represents an
interval I to J now I have to tell you
which part in y I should compare V with
so that's given by and that's given by
the shift s so when I'm telling you I
have a node V and I have shift s that
means this node V represents an interval
i j in X and that's compared with I plus
s to J plus s in y okay same same length
here same length here just shifted by S
so the tree distance will be represented
by this this uh this tuples V and S V is
a node s is a shift
okay so now how do I Define it at the
leaf level
and the leaf level if you have ah node I
here and so you will compare x i with y
i plus s so these are just single
entries these it will be one if they ma
if they don't match and if it will be 0
if they match so it's basically Hamming
distance it's just one entry okay and
for the internal nodes I will be
defining three distance recursively so
what do you do here
if you are at an internal node we you
will be looking at its kids his children
V 0 V 1. so on
and you have the shift s right so V is
saying hey compare me with uh these uh
if it's i j i plus s j plus s mean y so
what the children will do the children
will look at this shifted uh this
interval shifted here in y but it will
not just consider shift s it will
consider all possible shapes it will
consider all possible shapes as zero so
V 0 will consider all possible shift
sensitive S zero it will look at
whatever the three distances has
computed recursively right and but now
you have to pay for this if your if s0
is not s you will pay for this here
okay similarly for V1 V1 will consider
all possible ships S1 but if S1 is not
matching with s you have you will have
to pay for it so that's what the tree
distance is so you are basically looking
over all shapes for your kids and you
are seeing for which shift I get this as
minimum and then I'm adding up over the
children
so this is how the tree distance is
defined
okay so at the leaf level it's just
having distance
at the in when you go up and up you
define it recursively so for each kid
each child it's looking over all
possible ships s is zero but whenever s0
doesn't match with s you have to pay for
it here similarly S1 will be going over
all possible shapes whenever S1 is
doesn't match with as you have to pay
for it and then
this is okay
okay so the first question when you
define tree distance you have to ask
okay you have defined distance what is
this relationship with edit distance
so what and what was shown in this AKO
10 paper is the tree distance is always
greater than added distance
but it also bounded by
B times D of 80 distance what is b b is
the addity of the tree and D is the
depth of the tree
and if you are considering a balanced
completely then D is log b n so
basically it will be bounded by the
actual edit distance and B Times log b n
of that intestines and what is this
is basically you are looking at the root
root means what root means like entire X
you are looking at shift zero because
you have to compare inter X with entire
y so this is your tree distance at the
root we shift zero x y and this is
bounded by a distance to B Times log b n
of edit distance
that's the relationship between three
distance and Associates is there some
intuition for like why tree distance was
defined in the first place or like
what's what is it trying to capture so
the tree distance like oh okay so first
of all like we're trying to decompose it
into this independent part so it really
helps in the computation but one of the
difficult in handling at a distance is
like the shifts insertion then relation
that causes the sheets okay so here in
the tree distance like if you are not
considering Shield is having distance
but it's you are really paying for the
shapes when you are considering like you
are going from NCS to a zero S2 some
something else
and so overall like uh it gives you a
decomposition into independent problems
it handles the shares
and you get this uh
approximation chapters which is bounded
by the identity of the tree and the data
okay so that's the relationship the next
question is about efficiency okay so you
define tree distance it has it gives you
some approximation for edit distance but
how efficiently you can compute it
so first of all
so I said that the our main goal here is
to know whether whether my edit distance
is say below small K or above capital K
where capital K is this approximation b
d times k
so now that means I really want to know
whether my tree distance is less than
capital K
because if three distance is greater
than capital K then for sure I know edit
distance is greater than small K I can
return no
and otherwise if three distance is less
than K capital K then I know my edit
distance is less than capital K and I
can return yes
so really the problem that we are trying
to solve whether my tree distance is
less than capital K
okay
so previously I was saying hey look at
the children consider all possible
shapes
but actually we do not need to consider
all possible shapes it's okay to
consider the shapes around plus minus K
around s
because if you consider anything more
than that you will be paying more than
Ka here which means your tree distance
will be greater than capital K
so anyway it's a no okay so that that
means like I can cap my shifts around
cap plus minus K around s okay so this
is called capped tree distance
but is this enough
to get a good algorithm uh no because
like okay so this is the definition of
distance so now we are looking at the
sheets plus minus K around small s
and you are capping it at key as well so
this is your capped tree distance but
now even with this capped tree distance
if you're looking at the leaves how many
leaves does it have it has n leaves you
have to consider K shapes around each of
these Leaf so which means your
computation even at the leaf level is
ordered in k and if your capital K is
too large then it's very expensive
okay so you cap it which is great but
just capping doesn't help you to get a
good efficient algorithm
so then what do you have to do
well yes now you have to approximate
tree distance as well so trade distance
is already giving you an approximation
of edit distance but just Computing tree
distance exactly is not too helpful so
you have to approximately distance as
well so maybe two approximation or any
constant Factor approximation for three
distance is fine so let's just do that
so what we'll try to do we'll try to get
an additive approximation for tree
distance okay
ah
so beta V will be the additive
approximation at node B so how much
additive approximation can I allow at
the root if I'm looking for say two
approximation
that's a question for this
so I want to know through whether tree
distance is less than capital K
now I'm allowing two approximations so
it's okay like if it's K to K it's fine
so then I can allow an additive factor
of plus K right or some constant times k
at the root so I can allow additive
factor of plus k at the root
uh
and similarly so let's define this beta
V to be the additive approximation that
we allow at node V okay
so how do you how do you do that like
what we are going to do we saw that the
considering all possible ships is a
problem
like if you are considering all K shapes
I have to pay NK at the leaf level so
what we are going to do we are going to
consider a subset of the sheets
we will be considering shifts only at an
interval of beta V so we are not going
to consider all shapes we are going to
consider shapes at an interval of beta B
so how much additive Factor does it add
to like if it happened that the optimal
is wanted to select this shift I am not
considering this one but I am
considering something nearby within plus
minus beta V so I'll be paying that in
my
in here
so we will be off by plus minus constant
times beta V okay so plus minus beta V
so we will be considering about K Over
beta V shapes to get a better V additive
approximity
so my running time will be roughly
proportionate to 1 over beta V when I am
considering ah beta V
ariety so the question is okay at the V
at the root I can allow an additive
factor of K
or at the node v i can allow a beta V
but there how do I distribute this
additive Factor
around these kids
so what would you do
so you are trying to additively
approximate the three distances every
node what I say to you the other root I
can allow for an additive factor of
capital K
now say the root has B children
what do you think should be the additive
approximation Factor at this B children
where we can allow
just divide by B just divided by B right
distributed equally among its kids if
you do that
what happens to the additive Factor at
the leaf level
you're starting with capital K which was
much less than n
and leaves right you are dividing equal
equally so it will be much less than one
right
which means at the leaf level you have
to consider all caches which means you
have to pay NK
it doesn't help
so there comes this very nice idea of
precision sampling Lemma from
uh This Way kitchen paper actually the
Precision sampling Lemma has a root in
streaming literature for computing
frequency moments Heavy Hitters and so
on which basically says like
you can allow for much larger additive
errors so you have to allow for much
larger additive errors than simply
simply dividing this bit of equally
because at the leaf level you need to
have much larger identity weather you
cannot say hey my at least level my
additive error is less than one
so the Precision sampling limit says you
can allow much larger additive error at
your children but still when you add up
these estimates you will get a better V
additive error at your
so the Precision sampling lever so it's
like it there is it says there existed
distribution in fact exponential
distribution works you will be selecting
some precisions U1 U2 to u b
independently from this distribution and
then you will be setting the additive
Factor at your children
uh beta V times the Precision
okay so this is how you will set it and
what how and what is the and it and uh
expected value of this one over uh is
poly log n
okay so let's process this a little bit
so what is my Beta VH beta VH is beta V
times uh so which means beta V over poly
log n in fact you can think about it as
log Square n okay
so the beta VH is beta V over log Square
n
and your B is going to be much larger
than log Square n so essentially we're
getting much higher additive error here
and over the depth your additive error
is going to increase by log Square n log
Square n equals Square uh so at the end
you will get log log n over or to the
power order of D at depth d
okay so this is how your additive error
uh
decreases so it doesn't decrease by too
much
so the expected running now and if I'm
looking at expected running time I told
you my running time depends on 1 over
this beta VH because my shifts that you
will be considering is K Over beta v h
so it's really proportionate to this so
this becomes like um so basically your
running time increases Again by a factor
of log squared n at every level so
overall your running time becomes login
to the Power log BN because that's your
depth and you do it over all nodes so
you're overall your running time is in
Times log n to the Power log b n
and if you set your B to be login to the
power border of one over Epsilon as you
can see your added is really large okay
so then your running time becomes n to
the OnePlus Epsilon your overall
approximation Factor becomes poly lock
so that's your
eql card
it's not quite the equivalent
so now I'm going to try to make take
this algorithm
and make it dynamic how much time do I
have
really
not till 15.
okay okay
so very fast here
[Music]
to modify the static algorithm well we
are trying to we were trying to make the
static algorithm pretty efficiently we
did that using shift specification so we
need to use another concept of active
node
okay so what is an active node so we
call a node active
so each mean remember each V represents
an interval okay and you have a
Precision which is telling you what
additive factor is allowed at that node
okay so we will call a node active if
that interval is greater than the
Precision
otherwise we will call it inactive so
what does that mean so suppose you have
an interval of length five
okay and you say hey I can allow
additive approximation factor of 10 plus
minus 10 at that node so then it's an
inactive node because IV is less than
beta V so in that case like if your
interval length is 5 then you know that
tree distance is bounded by five
you can do all substitutions at that
five elements your three distress is
bounded by five you are saying hey give
me an additive again give me an estimate
within additive factor of plus minus 10.
then 0 is a good estimate to return
there
so for all inactive nodes you can just
return zero
so that means like you can prune away
all the inactive nodes you don't even
have to
handle them at all so you only consider
active nodes and what we can show that
that number expected number of active
nodes is actually n over capital K this
Factor is quality
okay so if you had just considered
activeness so forget our ship
specification if I had shown you the
analysis based on just this active notes
I will say hey I will just do my
computation only on active nodes I will
prune the inactive nodes and I will
consider all possible sheets
now all possible ships are capital K
where I would actually had still got the
same running time as we got here
see in fact you could have done this
analysis for the static algorithm just
using active node and not ship
specification in fact I think that's
what the EQ algorithm does we just
consider active node doesn't consider
ship specification
but for dynamic algorithm you need to
consider both shift specification and
active node we also have to modify this
definition a little bit so I will not
worry with that like how you cap that
resistance because the Captree distance
previously
um
didn't allow like having some certain
inequalities to hold at the internal
nodes but anyway so we have to change
the definition a little bit as well
so we have shift specification and
active nodes so let's look at the fast
step okay so the first step
where we consider only substitutions in
x and substitutions in y
so that's a kind of a simpler case we
are not allowing insertion changes in so
we are considering any Distance by the
way just the changes that are happening
dynamically we are only allowing
substitutions in X and substitutions it
works so it has an advantage like the
structure of the Precision tree
which is built on X like you you see
some asymmetry here right it's a
Precision tree like these we are calling
that calling the tree Precision tree
because this so much depends on the
Precision sampling limits we will just
call it Precision tray so the structure
of the Precision tree built on X it does
not change what does that mean that
means at every internal node V the
interval that it represents like I to J
That Remains the Same because you are
just doing substitution you are not
doing any insertion deletion so the
structure remains intact which is kind
of an advantage
algorithm is very simple like it's
saying hey we compute all the estimates
for which the tree distance might have
been affected by the substitutions
okay so this is our algorithm for when
we are just handling substitutions so
then I have to tell you like how many
nodes are affected by your substitution
okay so let's zoom in to these pictures
a little bit better
so what we can show that if a
substitution happens I mean X
then the nodes that are affected they
form a single root to Leaf path okay so
only one node at every level there are
some these orange nodes are basically
telling you like oh these these are not
affected but when you are Computing the
tree distance you have to look at the
children so you have to look at the
estimate at the orange node okay so only
these gray nodes are affected photo
um substitution at X
the substitution at Y is little bit
trickier as I have told you it's pretty
asymmetric like when you are doing this
Precision sampling tree
so substitution at y might affect more
nodes at every level but what we can
still show that the number of nodes that
are affected if you look at the starting
interval and the end interval
uh it's it's about order of K order of
capital K
uh
I'm confused about
boots by the K just be just being you
know like some fraction of n
Capital kit yeah or is that the approx
Factor so this is like so you are trying
to be so you really want this capital K
to be as close as to small okay because
you are trying to install this Gap
version edit distance lesson small key
or greater than capital K okay so
capital K if you can bring like if you
can have capital K to be 10 times small
okay then you have a 10 approximation
Factor here our capital K is b d times
small K because our approximation factor
is B times okay so it's poly log times
small
small okay and we are not looking at
this three distance problem where we are
trying to find out whether the right
three distance is less than capital K or
not but so should I think of capital K
as much smaller than n
capital
critical K is small K times
approximation Factor so depending on
is much smaller than is
okay so Capital case the approximation
Factor times your entity
so depending on what you're small okay
okay so anyway so you can add it in y
will affect that what we can show that
it affects multiple nodes but the
interval that is pans is about order of
capital K
okay so now let's look at like what
happens like so if you are looking at
the leave that means it can affect
capital K leaves right and if I am
considering even one shift
add this capital K leads my update time
will be order of capital K which can be
too high
but what we can show that not too many
of these Leaf nodes are active
so you really need to use the concept of
active nodes here to show really not too
many of these are active so it's fine
and you also need shift specification
because even if you are looking at one
node if you have to consider all
possible K shapes then it's again too
costly your object time is capital okay
so you need both ship specification and
active nodes and after you do that you
can bound your update time to be poly
login
okay so now let's look at the more
challenging case and in fact this if you
if you understand this part of this um
modification then after that the fully
Dynamic one you still require more ideas
but
the main ideas are kind of here
okay so this second part where you are
allowing substitutions in x
and all possible edits in y previously
we were allowing substitutions in X and
substitutions in y now I'm allowing
substitutions in Excel substitutions in
X but all possible insertion relation
substitutions in y okay so the advantage
still the Precision tree which is built
on X does structure does not change
but now there is a big challenge here
if you delete one symbol here of Y
suppose you deleted the first symbol of
Y so basically then the string shifted
right the Y shifted so whatever you are
comparing before for a we take any node
in X whatever you are comparing before
you are comparing it to something else
like this dark green light green okay so
it's like this is a different different
segment than the segment shifted by one
so essentially all your tree distance
estimates
all on all nodes all shades should
change
if you make even one deletion in y
okay so that's a big problem
so how do you overcome that
So to that we have to bring in some more
ideas so what we do
so we observe that okay so ultimately
what we are trying to do we are trying
to understand whether edit distance is
less than small K or greater than
capital K right so now if your edit
distance is less than small k
then what we know
that in your X and Y there are K
positions where edits happens
right but beyond that there is this K
plus 1 segments which are exact matches
which are exact matches right there
exists a decomposition of X and Y such
that there are K edit positions and
there are K plus 1 segments which
exactly matches if I can obviously
maintain this decomposition I am done I
don't have to do anything else so we
cannot we do not know how to maintain
this decomposition dynamically but we do
know how to maintain
this decomposition
so what does this decomposition it's
still partitions Y into this K plus 1
segments it still finds a matching
segment in x
but this matching segments now can
overlap or there could be gaps so from
this you cannot construct the error
distance but you can still find this
matching segments
okay so we do this Dynamic decomposition
and that takes a order K query time
order one update time
okay so that's your first idea and the
second one
is now in we want to estimate tree
distance x y
what we maintain instead is tree
distance between x and x
okay one good
okay so we are estimating x and x though
we want to estimate X and Y
how does that help
okay so we so we want to estimate X and
Y right so suppose I want to estimate
tree distance v s x y so I'm looking at
node V
I should have been looking at I plus s j
plus F in y
so instead of that let's look at a
bigger interval I plus is minus capital
K J plus S Plus K okay remember you have
to consider sheets which are within plus
minus K so what we claim that when we
are trying to estimate the tree distance
v s x Y where V is I to J the only
substring of Y that is relevant for this
computation is within this I plus s
minus K to J plus S Plus K this is just
coming because you have to consider
ships within plus minus k okay
if it happens that this substring
is entirely contained within this
matching region
that means there is a matching substring
over X which exactly matches here
okay so this is a shifted by S Prime
this exactly matches
so it happens that if I'm looking at the
Precision tree built on X and X if I
just change the shift from s to S Plus S
Prime whatever the tree distance you
will get here will be exactly same as
the tree distance as here
so we can just copy
and do you know how to maintain this X
on x you know by now
because only substitutions are happening
in X and X so I told you like how to
maintain
uh the Precision tree Dynamic element
when this substitution happens so you
know how to maintain this and at this
point you are just copying from that to
get an estimate for X Y
and if it happens that this region which
is relevant for me actually handles this
actually contains this edit point
then you have to make some then you have
to recompute
but there are not too many such edit
points there are only K of them
and as we have shown you here
that with one edit not to the whatever
is affected we can handle it so with K
edits it will be just multiplied by
small k
and
we can also we can we don't have to do
do this computation every time when an
edit happens we can do it after K EDS we
can do it in a lazy fashion so on
amortized uh your update time will still
remain
okay
so obviously I didn't tell you how to
handle the fully Dynamic case but fully
Dynamic case uses the same data
structure as in the substitution in X
and insertion deletion in y it has to do
some more work because in that case
because you are allowing insertion
deletion in X this pick also becomes
unstable so you have to work with some
uniquely leveled strings and so on but
the main idea really is embedded in the
case where you have substitution in X
and insertion relations in y
okay so that's it
so we get the polyog approximate like we
often uh
this theorem which gives you polylog
approximation with entity Epsilon update
time or some polynomial approximation
with the polynomial object time main
open question can you get a constant
Factor approximation in N to the Epsilon
of the time lower bounds in the dynamic
setting well if you can get anything
better than into the Epsilon update time
you will get better static algorithm and
that would be great but maybe there are
lower bounds that in the dynamic setting
because it doesn't fold in static
straining may be holes in Dynamic
settings so what can you say about lower
bounds
and then so our bounds are on
expectation the update time bounces on
expectations so can you make it high
probability from amortized to your
scales these are like immediate kind of
open immediate questions but the main
open questions are here
okay so thank you
[Applause]
um okay so since we're short on time now
I think we'll take questions likewise if
you have questions for uh but please
um talk to her
um and we'll be having a coffee break
now until 11 45 so please come back at
11 45.
thank you